the cause of all the catastrophes we are
seeing today is overpopulation we are
proud to unveil the only practical
remedy to humanity's greatest problem
are you ready doctor yes I'm ready
Wow that is wild isn't it it's just wild
that's Dave Dave Johnson everybody and
Carol he never struck me as the kind of
guy who'd go get small downsizing takes
the pressure right off plus you're
really making a difference you mean all
that crap about saving the planet yeah
downsizing is about saving yourself we
live like kings got best houses best
restaurants Cheesecake Factory got three
of them in leisure laying your $52,000
translates to 12.5 million dollars to
live on but life Wow
do you understand that you will undergo
the permanent and irreversible medical
procedure commonly known as downsizing
and that your bodies will be
approximately point zero three six four
percent of their current mass and volume
nervous little Missy on the other side
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the smart world is filled with things to
see
[Music]
sometimes you think we're in the normal
world and something happens
oh my god you realize we're not
[Music]
you